[Musique]
christian ursulet bonjour bonjour béa
prend feu rouge alors vous êtes en effet
ex directeur de la rs vous êtes un haut
fonctionnaire aujourd'hui à la retraite
par rapport à cette fonction néanmoins
vous revenez justement sur ce qui a
marqué vos derniers mois en quelque
sorte en tant que directeur de l'agencé
régionale de la santé en martinique
puisqu'en février 2016 il ya tout juste
deux ans vous allez retirer vos clichés
à brûler sur l'absence de dynamique de
concertation et de communication on
dirait même de notre point de vue
d'information transparente peut-être
plus que de communication l'absence de
dynamique de concertation qui pouvait
être le ferment de nouvelles polémiques
polémique là aussi j'ai envie de
remplacer par des interrogations
légitimes des uns et des autres en
parlant de la population martiniquaise
alors est-ce à dire christian ursulet
que cette note que vous adressiez alors
au ministère de la santé était restée
jusque-là lettre morte en quelque sorte
jusqu'à ces derniers mois
oui d'abord plusieurs précisions damman
ma réaction le fait d'utiliser ce
document qui est un document de huit
pages là c'est pas un document d'une
demi-page une petite fête comme ça qui
fait le point qui dit pourquoi en plus
oui c'est argumenté la cité il faudrait
qu'on pas pourquoi il faudrait changer
de politique
je fais pas réaction quand je me suis
rendu compte qu'on était ce que je ne
savais pas du tout en fait un conte est
arrivé au stade où il fallait que le
syndicat cdmt de la rs aujourd'hui
montent au créneau pour dire qu'il
n'acceptait pas la mise au placard d'un
certain nombre de personnes et qu' il ne
comprenait pas le manque d'applications
et de jeux vous dire de dynamisme aussi
du ministère encore aujourd'hui en 2010
sur cette affaire-là
et donc je rappelle que c'est pas jojo
exhibé ce courrier là mais c'était pas
là le seul courrier ce n'est pas la
seule note n'était pas seule
intervention où il y avait des débats et
je dois dire que cette affaire est
tellement difficile même pour la
martinique que il faut saluer aussi
longue où le travail de ceux qui à mon
avis a dû être mis au placard pendant un
moment qui évite godard qui est un
collègue qui ici depuis des décennies
qui est marié à une batterie qu'est-ce
qui est celui qui en 99 à exhiber de la
dass j'étais là ce moment comme
inspecteur le dossier du chlordécone
c'est lui qui a exhibé sa avec
évidemment un certain nombre de à
l'époque de coups sur la tête de sa
direction et des autorités pour essayer
de faire que les choses vont soit
maîtrisée ne sortent pas comme ça etc
c'est sûr qu'il y avait des problèmes à
son bras et nous avons fait un tel
boulot avec vos problèmes avec les plans
qui sont sortis le premier plan
chlordécone depuis 2008 le deuxième
après 2010 il faut dire que beaucoup
malgré tout ça quand les cours d'école a
été quand même pris à bras le corps en
tout cas au niveau de l'état avec des
collectivités des associations et que
nous avons hélas encore eric godard
était de la est avec moi j'étais
directeur à ce moment là nous avons pu
avec les préfets de l'époque au
contraire ouvrir la communication à
l'ensemble du monde des os des
associatifs et tout est fait un des
réunions régulières effectivement
assurée dans cette note vous n'indiquez
pas que rien n'avait été fait c'est pas
ça vous tiriez néanmoins la sonnette
d'alarmé quand même sur le ton qui était
employé dans dans la rédaction c'était
une note écrite
vous diriez la sonnette d'alarmé et est
ce que vous avez entendu vous avez été
entendu à ce moment là c'est ça la
question alors exactement et tiré des
larmes parce que non seulement on était
loin du compte par rapport à nous oui
vous vous étiez inquiet vous disiez bon
il ya des choses qui ont été faites mais
il faut aller plus loin d'améliorer ça
qu'on le préconise ya loin du compte
parce que je pensais qu'il fallait
soutenir sérieusement toutes les études
qui était faite parce que les gens ont
tendance à penser que la rsa induite
c'est elle qui pilote la felco dit que
non on n'est que sur le segment santé
avec des pouvoirs assez limité et bien
évidemment il faut le comprendre bon
mais nous tirions la salle d'armes sur
l'ensemble est bon moi je sais pas
content en tout cas parce que je savais
que justement les caennais c'est une
national du cancer à l'époque est en eux
en eux en avant 2013 n'avait pas
financer les études de karuprostate de
la guadeloupe et que ou alors qu'il
fallait absolument pour scientifiquement
faire le parallèle dans ta marie lou
peut être certain de la 2d fait
finalement le tour d'icônes sur les
cancers notamment la prostate faire
cette étude
en parallèle en martinique et le zinc
avait financé à financer à ce moment là
en 2013
cette disons la mise en route la
méthodologie enfin le pula pour la
martinique et a coupé les financements
en 2014
et donc c'était vraiment pour nous donc
j'entends maintenant 10 ou plus haut
niveau nous avons financé étudier tout
ça il ya là aussi un gros problème
oui alors je vous cite un dans une
récente interview que vous avez donné à
notre consoeur de france antilles les la
salle dj le sentiment à ce moment là un
et quand vous faisiez cette note
il y a deux ans j'ai eu le sentiment
qu'on régressait sur un certain nombre
de thèmes comme celui des fameuses
limite maximum résiduelles autorisé ces
lmr que les contrôles n'étaient pas
suffisants donc je sais pas si ça sonne
l'alerté sur les circuits informels et
même sur les circuits formels la
communication avait ralenti les réunions
ne se faisait plus en préfecture et donc
ça me motive et jour alerté le ministère
on va demander dans le jeu vous dire je
veux que la hongrie c'est pour les
raisons que je viens de dire
alors qu'il aurait fallu aller plus loin
sur les études et c'est ma fête ensuite
les maires ont passé en 2013 bon il y
avait une évolution en dit long sur le
taux qui était retenu au lieu de 20
microgrammes
on passait à des choses plus subtil mais
qui faisait que peu plus de produits ce
qui a distribué sans la même rigueur au
niveau des contrôles d'accord donc là ça
me gênait on a encore évolué la sacem et
si vous avez l'impression que c'est plus
une vision des choses est que je veux la
côte il a donc on a et donc je l'a aussi
poussé qu'ils ont lancée mais je veux
dire que c'était une situation un peu
général parce que à ce moment là en
martinique on se trouvait en réunion
alors que nous avions vraiment batailler
pour qu'elle se taise régulièrement ces
réunions pouvait se tenir encore en
préfecture il y avait la moitié des gens
qui venaient y compris du monde
associatif y compris le monde
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est un drôle
général une dérogation les gens et ça il
ne faut pas que ça puisse opérer
est-ce que vous indiquiez c'est que
c'était du rôle de l'état en quelque
sorte en quelque sorte de ré impulse est
justement une certaine vigilance et puis
par exemple le troisième plan il était
beaucoup plus étalés que les deux
premiers avec moins de moyens financiers
alors que encore une fois comme je vous
dis le cours du won c pour on est là
pour des décennies voire des siècles et
on était encore loin sont rendu compte
alors alors justement il ya deux volets
dans ce dossier j'ai envie de dire bon
il ya le volet des causes inde et des
origines de la pollution
bon avec notamment maintenant un aspect
judiciaire un con qu'on va laisser de
côté ce matin mais néanmoins clique qui
est important aussi donc les causes les
responsabilités et puis ensuite il y as
doivent payer
voilà c'est un leurre règle ça c'est un
principe puis aussi le principe de
précaution de prévention je dirais
post-catastrophe ainsi on parce que
c'est quand même une catastrophe
sanitaire incombe est ce que nous venons
de santé publique
alors oui donc sur les contrôles et puis
et puis comment comment en sortir alors
pas d'un coup on le sait mais
progressivement alors il ya surtout
s'assied sur les contrôles il faut être
clair le comment on peut dire comment on
peut dire que pour l'europe et pour
l'ensemble des pesticides la limite
maximum qui est retenu pour la
distribution des aliments dans les
circuits officiels évidemment est de 10
microgrammes par kilo et que pour cette
affaire du chlordécone en reste à 20
donc l'objectif de tout chacun face à la
corée c'est que ça a été ça a été
modifié oui bon on va là c'est ça c'est
ça avec vous la nouvelle et validité de
deux de l'âne de l'ansès en fait on
graisse
we had et à des taux de personnes en eau
et en redescendre en dessous lgv est
aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il ya des
discussions qui sont déjà enclenchées
entre le ministère de la santé et
l'union européenne pour réviser la faire
modifier cet effet modifier sa bon mais
mais là ça touche quoi des intérêts
économiques vous le dire c'est ça tout
ça touche à mon sens et des terres
économique savait que plus vous limitez
donc de ce qui est cool devises et les
viandes est grave c'est différent mais
plus à exclure elle introduit des
circuits de distribution puisque le
contrôle va montrer qu'il ya des traces
etc
donc on peut pas le distribuer donc ça
c'est un problème d'intérêt mais sur les
contrôles lui même nous n'avons jamais
fait quand je dis non c'est le les
pouvoirs et collectivement le travail à
fond parce qu'il y avait enfin quand
j'étais là à peu près c'est sans
contrôle qui était fait dans les
circuits par an sur sur la martinique
c'est largement insuffisant
il fallait il faut tout contrôler en
fait tout passe en poussant de chaque
produit
mais je vous dire il faut multiplier ces
contrôles aussi bien sur les produits
dans les supermarchés sur les marchés
dans l'est au bord des routes etc
parce que l'objectif doit être vraiment
de projets déjà pourquoi
indiquait alors justement parlant de la
population martiniquaise dans votre
propos aussi il y à cette phrase que
j'ai retenue vous dites que selon vous
il appartient donc aux martiniquais et
guadeloupéens qui sont les plus les plus
concernés de se mobiliser s'il n'y a pas
une très forte pression
si cela n'est pas jugé prioritaire
d'abord par la population et l'état
lui-même vous dites ne sera pas un petit
peu secoué l'état marchera que si nous
marchons et c'est à nous d'agir mais
c'est tout à fait appel à une action
collective absolument c'est une rires
ajouté c'est une réalité est à mon sens
et pas que sur cette affaire-là
il faut comprendre que nous devons nous
prendre à bras le corps avant tout même
au niveau de l'état qu'est ce que vous
voyez il ya des divergences considérable
vous croyez que toutes les
administrations de l'état le ministère
de la santé en accord avec le ministère
de l'agriculture dont l'intérêt est
justement de permettre que les produits
soient diffusés avec évidemment une
garantie mais il ya des intérêts
divergents
il ya des débats donc les martiniquais
le second enigma bien protégés que si
ils se battent sérieusement et que s'ils
ont un plan est aussi à une unité si les
divergences politiques ne prennent pas
le pas sur l'unité à ce niveau là merci
à christian ursulet
[Musique]